let's look live at i-15 give me a
location here folks the super is blocked
there we're seeing no delays northbound
and southbound that is looking at the
speedway as we are getting ready of
course for edc tomorrow expect a lot of
traffic and through the weekend
for electric daisy carnival it's back
been here a decade and will be taken
over this weekend the festival now
returning after being cancelled due to
the pandemic right now people are
starting to show up who are either
staying or camping on the grounds joe
moeller joining us live from the las
vegas motor speedway with what you need
to go if attending this weekend
if you're in the northeast part of the
valley and you do notice an increase in
traffic edc may be to blame we'll give
you a live look at the speedway here at
this hour again this does start tomorrow
but people were already showing up early
this morning
we're from albuquerque new mexico we got
here early this morning like 10 o'clock
people from all over the country are
making their way to las vegas to catch
their favorite artists at edc those with
rvs and campers started entering
thursday morning for camping we're
trying to avoid the long lines in the
past we've had to wait like six hours to
get in cassandra felix says it gets busy
thursday and friday for a cost attendees
can take shuttles from the strip general
parking is free and upgraded parking is
available all of my friends and i are
vaccinated copin 19 protocols are in
place show proof of vaccination or a
negative test we are hyped that they're
requiring you to be vaccinated or to
prove that you tested negative for
covert i don't know if i'd be super
comfortable not being vaccinated going
to something like this edc is a business
boost for not only the strip but the
north part of the valley many hotels in
the area including aliante are sold out
take a look at the prices on expedia
strip hotel rooms are several hundred
dollars some are a thousand dollars a
night traffic will be heavy in this area
felix says pack your patience i say get
here the sooner the better
just because so many people are coming
in today and tomorrow
now back out here live you're taking
another look at the speedway the final
preparations are being done right now
the opening ceremony is tomorrow at five
the festival goes through the entire
weekend another thing to keep in mind
that a lot of people will be leaving
monday morning so if you do see traffic
monday the edc may be blamed for that as
well reporting live at the speedway john
muller live local now